we're not teaching often I think kids
the skills that will actually make them
successful in life understanding history
is super important but that isn't what's
going to make the difference between a
successful business person and not what
is is have you got the right mindset
have you got the right attitude have you
got communication skills can you work as
a team can you be a good leader can you
manage money can you have conversations
with investors in a way that's going to
give them confidence that they're not
throwing money away these are all the
things that are going to make you
successful in life and we don't spend
nearly enough time uh teaching children
about that